you have
work on pseudo random functions what are
those
what uh what's the difference between
those and the generators
random number generators okay let's
start how do they work let's uh
let's uh go back to sudokan and number
generation
yes first of all people think of the
surah hundred majority
generates random number not true because
i don't believe
that from nothing you can get you can
you can get uh something so nothing for
nothing
but the randomness you cannot create out
on nothing but what you can do
is that you can be expanded so in other
words
if you give me somehow 300 random bits
truly random beats
then i can give you 300 300 million 300
trillions 300 quadrillions as many as
you want
random bits so that even though i tell
you the recipe
by which i produce these bits but i
don't tell you
the initial 300 random numbers i give
them secret
and you see all the beats i produce so
far
if i if you were to bet given all the
bits produced so far
what is the next bit in my sequence
better than 50 50.
of course 50 50 anybody can guess right
but to be
inferring something you have to be a bit
better then
the effort to to do this extra bit
is so enormous that is the fact of
random
so that is a sort of random generator
are these expanders
of secret randomness which goes
extremely
fast okay let's say what's the standards
of secret randomness
beautifully put okay so every time every
time somebody who if you're a programmer
is using a function
that's not called pseudorandom it's
called random usually in all these
programming languages and it's
generating different
uh that's essentially expanding the
secret
randomness but they should and in the
past actually most of the library they
used
something pre modern cryptography
unfortunately will be better served
don't take
300 real seed random number
and uh and then expand them properly as
we know now
uh but that has been a very
um old idea in fact one of the best
philosophers
have debated the wave of the world was
deterministic or probabilistic yes very
big questions right
does god play dice exactly einstein says
it does
it doesn't but in fact now
we have a language that even at alberta
time
was not around but it was this
complexity of a modern
complexity-based cryptography and now we
know that
if the universe has 300 random beats
whether where is random or probabilistic
or
deterministic it doesn't matter because
you can expand
this initial seed of randomness forever
in which
all the experiments you could do all the
inferences you could do
all the things you can do they are you
are not be able to distinguish them from
truly random
so if you are not able to distinguish
from this super duper pseudo randomness
of the really different things that's
what i say somebody had to become a real
philosophical so
for things to be different but i don't
have in my lifetime
in my lifetime of the universe any
method to set them aside
well i should be intellectually honest
say well
pseudorandom investment function is as
good as random
do you think true randomness is
possible and what does that mean
so i practically speaking exactly as you
said if you're being honest
the the the pseudo-randomness approaches
through randomness pretty quickly
but is it is it uh maybe this is a
philosophical question
is there such a thing as true randomness
well the answer is actually maybe but if
there
exists most probably is
expensive to get and uh
and uh and in any case if i give you one
of mine
um you will never tell them apart
yeah by no any other shape no matter how
much you work on it so in some sense
if it exists or not it really is a quote
philosophical sense in the
um colloquial way to say that we cannot
somehow pin it down
you